[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden afirmó que no pedirá disculpas a
China por el derribo del globo
denominado como espía sin embargo afirmó
estar abierto a hablar con su homólogo
silvin y reiteró que no quiere una nueva
guerra fría con el gigante asiático
la organización amnistía internacional
calificó de letal y racista la represión
de las protestas en Perú el organismo
Indicó que se trata de ataques
generalizados con la intención de
castigar y silenciar en los que se ha
utilizado ilegítimamente armas letales
cerca de 60 personas han muerto las
manifestaciones
los presidentes de Colombia Gustavo
Petro y de Venezuela Nicolás Maduro
mantuvieron un breve encuentro en la
frontera de sus países allí ratificaron
un acuerdo comercial que forma parte de
los avances hacia la normalización de
relaciones entre las naciones vecinas
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden afirmó este jueves que
ordenaría el derribo de cualquier objeto
aéreo que amenace la seguridad del país
el mandatario también aseguró que está
abierto a hablar con su homólogo chino
sillín y reiteró que no quiere una nueva
guerra fría con el gigante asiático esta
fue su primera declaración después de
que las autoridades estadounidenses
derribarán hace 12 días un globo chino
que volaba en el espacio aéreo del país
un globo calificado de espía por
Washington y de civil por Beijing casi
dos semanas después de haber derribado
este artefacto chino que sobrevolaba el
territorio estadounidense el presidente
Joe biden se dirigió al país según él su
destrucción Envía un claro mensaje
contra cualquier violación de la
soberanía de Estados Unidos
estén seguros que si un objeto aéreo
supone una amenaza para la seguridad
estadounidense lo Haré derribar el
mandatario añadió que no quería una
nueva guerra fría entre los dos países
Espero poder hablar con el presidente
She e ir al fondo de este caso
sostiene que se trataba de un globo
destinado a recoger datos meteorológicos
y que se adentró involuntariamente en el
espacio aéreo estadounidense el
incidente desencadenó un impase
diplomático entre ambos países y debido
a ello el secretario de estado Anthony
blinquen se vio obligado a suspender una
visita a territorio chino china por su
parte también hizo señalamientos contra
Washington de presunto espionaje
desde mayo del año pasado Sin la
aprobación de las autoridades chinas
pertinentes Estados Unidos ha lanzado
varios globos de Gran altitud desde
Estados Unidos que han realizado vuelos
continuos por todo el mundo sobrevolando
ilegalmente el espacio aéreo de China y
otros países pertinentes al menos 10
veces desde el incidente del globo chino
otros tres objetos no identificados han
sobrevolado el territorio estadounidense
y han sido derribados por las fuerzas
aéreas Pero biden dijo que las agencias
de inteligencias seguían buscando más
información
el presidente pidió además a su
administración que haga un mejor
inventario de los objetos que vuelan en
el cielo de Estados Unidos y anunció
haber establecido un diálogo con sus
aliados sobre lo que cree que es el
programa de espionaje de China
pasamos a Perú amnistía internacional
denunció el uso excesivo de la fuerza
por parte de las autoridades en las
protestas que iniciaron hace más de dos
meses la organización la calificó como
una represión letal y racista que ha
afectado principalmente a personas
indígenas y campesinas en palabras de la
directora para las Américas de esta
organización se trata de ataques
generalizados hacia la población con la
intención de castigar y silenciar a
quienes ejercen su derecho a la
manifestación anteriormente hablamos con
Pilar San Martín investigadora para
América de esta organización que nos
contaba que llevó amnistía internacional
a señalar que la represión durante el
estallido social ha tenido un sesgo
racista
Bueno lo que hemos analizado y es por lo
que decimos que ha habido ataques
generalizados en contra de la población
pero que además han tenido este sesgo
marcadamente racista contra personas
indígenas contra personas racializadas
contra personas campesinas es porque
realizamos un análisis Respecto a los
índices de homicidios verdad de muertes
que habían sido causados presuntamente
por la policía y el ejército durante las
manifestaciones y los niveles de
violencia en las manifestaciones en
distintas regiones y por ejemplo en
regiones como Lima
donde los niveles de violencia
registrados en las manifestaciones eran
similares a los niveles por ejemplo de
regiones como puno guayacucho sin
embargo estas últimas regiones que
concentran la mayoría de las personas
indígenas del país habían de alguna
manera acumulado el mayor porcentaje de
muertes verdad esto quiere decir o esto
nos indica efectivamente hay un mercado
sesgo racista porque no se actúa y la
policía no actúa de la misma manera
cuando la población no está racializada
que cuando la población lo está aparte
de esto hemos visto discursos sumamente
racistas por parte de las autoridades
Vimos a la presidenta Dina boluarte
incluso afirmar que la región de puno no
es Perú hemos visto como es estigmatiza
cómo se criminaliza diciendo que los
manifestantes son terroristas son
criminales sin que el estado haya
aportado ninguna prueba y es por eso que
consideramos que hay un mercado sesgo
discriminatorio en esta en esta
actuación los presidentes de Colombia
Gustavo Petro y de Venezuela Nicolás
Maduro mantuvieron un encuentro en el
puente atanasio girardot fronterizo
entre sus países allí ratificaron un
acuerdo comercial vigente desde hace 10
años pero en desuso tras la ruptura de
relaciones del anterior gobierno
colombiano con su país vecino ambos
mandatarios hablaron sobre el futuro de
estas relaciones y de lo que supone la
nueva firma
la firma de este acuerdo comercial
que actualiza todo lo que tiene que ver
con los aranceles que actualiza todo lo
que tiene que ver con los productos a
intercambiar las prioridades hecha las
bases hacia una nueva dinámica de
expansión del comercio entre Colombia y
Venezuela
hemos habilitado estos puentes
incluso uno Este que no no tenía el uso
nunca había sido usado hemos hecho
acuerdos de aduanas administrativos
etcétera el acuerdo parcial que acabamos
de firmar aún hay mucho por hacer
este viernes comienza en Río de Janeiro
uno de los festivales más conocidos del
mundo y los cariocas se preparan para el
espectáculo todos los días en algún
Rincón de esta ciudad brasileña una
escuela de samba ensaya para que todo
salga perfecto Durante los 75 minutos
que dura el desfile en el sambodromo
nuestros corresponsales estuvieron con
la escuela paraíso de tuiuchi y fueron
testigos de los grandes esfuerzos Esta
es la historia
[Música]
para ser reina de una escuela de samba
hace falta un torrente de energía y una
gran coordinación con los percusionistas
es considerada una de las mejores
bailarinas de la nueva generación de
sambistas
Yo casi siempre estoy escuchando
nuestros percusionistas porque mi cuerpo
es eso mi cuerpo es música y danza yo
coloco todos los instrumentos de la
batería en mi cuerpo
cada escuela de samba está dividida en
alas no pueden faltar los fascistas que
bailan la zamba un ala de bayanas las
mujeres mayores que representan la
tradición de la samba
Y por supuesto el abanderado y su
doncella que levantan el estandarte de
la escuela
delante de los jurados la bandera no
puede quedar enrollada ni caer ni
golpearse contra el suelo Tampoco puede
caer ningún elemento de nuestra ropa
mientras estamos danzando
el desfile en el sambodromo es una ópera
itinerante donde cada detalle importa
todos los años cada escuela tiene que
producir un espectáculo diferente y
presentar una trama original
desarrollada a través de la canción de
los disfraces y de la danza
el entusiasmo es un requisito
indispensable
La mejor parte ocurre antes aquí antes
del carnaval el espectáculo en el
sambódromo es para que el mundo lo vea
el espectáculo del pueblo El que
emociona De verdad está aquí el alma de
la escuela el alma del zambista están
aquí en el ensayo
y el público participa vibrando a cada
nota la Samba consigue reunir a
generaciones y personas desconocidas a
través de un sentimiento inexplicable
una pasión tan Arrolladora que permite
vencer Incluso el calor tórrido del
verano carioca
[Música]
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]